[Música]
biblioterapia que história é essa
eu escuto essa pergunta muitas vezes eu
poderia responder de diversas maneiras
mas eu prefiro fazer isso através de um
poema do ferreira gullar que se chama
muitas vozes e diz assim estamos todos
nós cheios de vozes que o mais das vezes
mal cabem em nossa própria voz
e tudo isso em ti se deposita e cala
até que de repente um susto uma ventania
que o poema dispara chama esses fósseis
a fala meu poema é um tumulto um alarido
basta apurar o ouvido
esse poema está no livro que se chama
muitas vozes que dialoga com essa imagem
que é dividir diz k weiss no livro teste
com a eth e que mostra o quanto de nós
fica submerso pela falta de expressão eu
sou uma psicóloga que cuida das pessoas
através da literatura apesar de pouca
gente conhecer esse termo ele é muito
antigo e ele consta no código brasileiro
de ocupações sob a responsabilidade da
biblioteconomia apesar dele ser
aplicável a várias outras áreas como a
psicologia à educação à saúde a cultura
literatura e muitas outras
de uma certa forma eu acredito que cada
um já tem uma certa intimidade com a
prática e o contato isso através de duas
perguntas
a primeira você já teve a impressão que
um livro funcionou como verdade
quero terapeuta pra você ele acolheu
você num momento de dificuldade no meio
suas angústias mostrou perspectivas que
você ainda não considerava e provocou
uma verdadeira transformação na sua vida
a segunda pergunta é conversando com
alguém
de vez em quando que atravessam um
pensamento
eu acho que essa pessoa precisava letal
livro e aí você recomenda ou prescreve
ou compra idade presente ou empresta
se você respondeu sim a qualquer uma
dessas perguntas é sinal que você já
vivenciou na pele o processo da
biblioteca a pia é hoje trabalho com a
bíblia terapia de duas maneiras
principais uma individualmente no
consultório onde eu tenho estantes de
livros que eu chamo da minha farmácia e
outra coletivamente através de rodas de
leitura que eu chamo de círculo de
biblioterapia que acontecem semanalmente
desde julho de 2011 até os dias atuais
e eu vou dar exemplos de como é que isso
funciona para que vocês percebam a
dinâmica desse trabalho no consultório
por exemplo eu recebi um paciente que
tinha 25 anos e sofria de convulsões
quando essas crises se manifestavam ele
ficava extremamente agressivo e ele
quebrava tudo colocando em risco a
própria segurança das pessoas que
estivessem próximas a ele
por conta dessa condição
a família o mantinha com a liberdade
cerceada
e ele cresceu assim já dizia a nise da
silveira que o melhor tratamento que
existe a liberdade
imagina você não ter liberdade talvez
por isso a agressividade se manifestasse
nas crises
diante dessa situação o que é que o
biblioterapia alta faz ele na verdade é
um relações públicas entre as pessoas o
contexto que elas estão vivendo e os
autores dos livros que possam dialogar
com aquela pessoa naquele momento então
eu peguei o notas do subsolo do
dostoievski e nessa edição de bolso que
vende no jornaleiro leu um trecho pra
ele e perguntei se ele gostaria de levar
pra casa pra conhecer um pouco melhor e
para me contar como é que tinha sido
esse encontro na semana seguinte
na semana seguinte eu perguntei como foi
você gostou do livro ele começou a
sacudir o livro fala se o que que é isso
aqui eu fiquei com medo
eu achei que ele ia quebrar o meu
consultório todo comigo lá dentro mas
para minha surpresa ele disse assim pra
mim parece que fui eu que escrevi quando
eu escuto isso eu fico com um alívio
muito grande porque eu sei que a pessoa
não está mais sozinha ela encontrou
alguém com quem conversar com alguém que
vai poder nomear angústia que ele está
sentindo e para nossa surpresa ao ler a
biografia do autor
ele descobriu que o 2o e heves que
sofria de epilepsia e que isso não
impediu e provavelmente até contribuiu
para que ele se tornasse um escritor
universal imortal e por conta disso esse
paciente começou a escrever sobre a
beleza da dor num outro exemplo eu
recebi uma pessoa uma mulher passando
por uma situação muito difícil de vida
ela estava num processo de separação de
um casamento de mais de 40 anos e
sofrendo tanto
que isso reverberou não sintoma porque o
sintoma também é uma voz é uma narrativa
que a gente precisa ouvir o que está
dizendo o corpo já que as palavras não
vem e ela teve um rompimento do
intestino ela teve procedimentos
cirúrgicos que deixaram ela face a face
com a finitude com a morte
ela se sentiu extremamente fragilizada
como se tudo tivesse desmoronando
a literatura tem um manancial
inesgotável para acolher essas situações
por exemplo a florbela espanca tem uma
por um poema chamado ruínas que diz
assim se é sempre outono ruir das
primaveras castelos 1 a 1 deixa os cair
que a vida é um contínuo de ruído de
palavras do rei das quimeras e deixa
sobre as ruínas crescer eras beijar as
pedras e florir que a vida é um contínuo
de ruir de palácio de renda as quimeras
deixa tombar teus ruth dos castelos
tenham ainda mais sonhos para erguê los
mais altos que as águias pelo há sonhos
que tomba derrocada louca
são como beijos de uma linda boca
deixa-os tombar e nesse trabalho
são muitas as vozes porque o autor chama
outro
florbela chamou cora coralina
eu sou o caule dessas trepadeiras sem
classe nascida na áfrica das pedras
bravias renitentes indomáveis pisadas
maltratadas e renascendo cora coralina
chama cecília meireles
aprendi com as primaveras a deixar me
cortar ea voltar sempre inteira ea cada
poema a gente vai
se regenerando vai vendo que não está só
cada poema tem uma energia por exemplo a
clarice lispector nesse contexto também
ajuda muito mas percebam como energia
muda na primeira página do paixão
segundo gh a clarice diz assim eu perdi
uma terceira perna que me impedia de
andar mas que fazia de mim o tripé
estável
estou diz organizada porque eu perdi o
que eu não precisava
isso é de tirar o fôlego não é isso é um
tratado filosófico e dentro desse
processo a literatura utilizada não só
para a nomeação angústias mas também
para abrir novas perspectivas e nesse
sentido a escrita ela é muito
incentivada no processo até inspirada
por adélia prado que escreveu ao buscar
palavras com que narrar minha angústia
já respira melhor a uns deus quer
doentes a outros escrevendo
então essa paciente foi incentivado a
escrever está com raiva tá com medo
tanto angústia escreve sem compromisso
com o valor literário compromisso com a
expressão pra expurgar isso pra arrancar
isso de você
e num segundo momento a escrita
ficcional
vamos inventar um novo personagem o que
você quer resgatar da sua vida o que
está aí submerso
se você fosse faria essa mulher que nova
mulher seria essa escreve o que ela
estaria fazendo dizendo
e esse processo resultou na publicação
de um livro que se chama escritas
libertária de ano de ângela pupin que me
deu alegria de estar aqui nesse nesse
público hoje
[Aplausos]
nesses dois exemplos é a gente percebe
que a escassez está muito próxima da
abundância e tem uma frase do saramago
no ano da morte de ricardo reis que diz
assim todos nós temos uma doença todos
nós somos uma doença digamos assim por
causa dela somos tão pouco mas também
por causa dela conseguimos ser tanto
então é esses foram exemplos de um
atendimento individual com biblioterapia
mais conforme eu contei em julho de 2011
começarão os círculos as rodas de
leitura nem sempre foi assim tão cheio
de gente no início às vezes iam duas
pessoas três pessoas mas isso não
importa porque se eu fizer um convite
pra vocês pensa naquela primeira
pergunta que eu fiz qual a ficou foi o
livro que já funcionou como um terapeuta
pra você que a impressão que você teve
não era que você estava lendo o livro
mas o livro estava lendo você pega esse
livro que você lembrou
imagina que você vai ler esse livro vai
marcar trechos que foram mais importante
pra você e vai lançar um convite para os
seus amigos para interessados que você
vai fazer uma roda de leitura com esse
livro chega no dia do encontro imagine a
situação você vai está em mais uma
leitura cada vez que a gente lê uma um
livro que nos afetou é como se a gente
ficasse raízes a gente vai ficando mais
é forte consistente ao partilhar essa
leitura com outras pessoas
o que acontece é uma bunda de
perspectivas
elas vão ver coisas que você nunca
sequer imaginou então aquela leitura que
foi tão significativa para você ela vai
se expandir como
países existem várias mágicas que
acontecem o que considero essas rodas de
leitura como revoluções sensíveis porque
a gente se ausenta do caos que a gente
está vivendo é um espaço para respirar
é um espaço pra alimentar o sonhar
o gastão bacelar fala que imaginar el
zentani arce lançar se a uma vida nova e
essas rodas de leitura elas foram também
muito inspiradas nessas antropólogos
francesa chamada michele petit que ela
tem esse livro a arte de ler ou como
resistir à adversidade
essa pesquisadora percorreu o mundo nos
países onde tinha mais escassez campos
de refugiados lugares de extrema pobreza
assolados por guerras e ela foi
conversar com os mediadores de leitura
desses lugares e o que eles relatavam
era justamente esses que esses lugares
representava uma forma de recuperar a
casa perdida num lugar que a gente possa
se alimentar de beleza o bartolomeu
campos de queirós ele diz que viver sem
esperança é como ter casa sem janela
nessa perspectiva a gente tá aí com um
nível de depressão muito alto de
medicalização muito alto não é o que é a
depressão a pessoa só vê uma saída ela é
insuportável então ela deprime
no ponto de vista da bíblia terapia quer
dizer que esse repertório atrofiado
é preciso ampliar esse repertório então
o fernando pessoa no livro do
desassossego ele diz que sonhar é
procurarmos nos e que ler é sonhar pela
mão de outrem e nesses espaços
a gente tem algumas premissas para
favorecer o acolhimento da diversidade
opiniões porque é isso que nos enriquece
então o saramago ele diz que a tentativa
de colonial tentativa de convencer o
outro é uma tentativa de colonização do
outro então nós fazemos um exercício de
cada um ter o espaço para falar a sua
opinião e depois calar para que o outro
também têm essa oportunidade
depois se alguém quiser mudar de opinião
é com cada uma decisão pessoal e nesse
percurso eu descobri que na inglaterra
um pesquisador chamado neu fru ndi
conseguiu comprovar que fazer rodas de
leitura substitui antidepressivo isso
incentivou que o governo adotasse
políticas públicas de saúde num programa
que se chama buxom prescription como nós
temos farmácias do sus lá eles têm
bibliotecas do sus e fazem as rodas de
leitura e que resgatam isso que é tão
ancestral das relações face-a-face
intercambiando experiências
intercambiando até nossas fragilidades
assim se faz uma partilha do sensível e
se fortalece as relações e as coragens e
nesse percurso que começou em 2010 2011
as experiências são tão ricas que eu
publiquei o livro em 2014 chamado
vivências em biblioterapia práticas do
cuidado através da literatura porque
isso tudo já estava transbordando uma
coisa muito boa gente tem vontade que
todo mundo fruto daquilo tem uma frase
do valentino dell maza que diz
compartilhar um gesto sem cálculos de
duas mãos abertas que já não sabem se
estão dando ou recebendo a partir da
publicação desse livro
várias pessoas me procuraram porque tem
esse chamado tenha-se amor aos livros e
à vontade de contribuir para um lugar
melhor pra gente viver e eu chamo essas
pessoas de bíblia família então já foram
quinze cursos e eu tenho orgulho de
dizer que a gente conhece uma árvore
pelos seus frutos e essas pessoas já
estão espalhadas pelo brasil fazendo as
suas próprias rodas partindo do seu
próprio universo como um poeta me ajudou
abre eu vou chamar o o leminski para me
despedir o poema se chama contra narciso
em mim eu vejo o outro e outro e outro
enfim dezenas vagões cheios de gente
centenas ou outro que há em mim é você
você e você assim como eu estou em você
eu estou nele em nós e só quando estamos
em nós estamos em paz
mesmo que estejamos a sós gratidão
[Aplausos]